bring on a pandemic I got cash that's
how I went bro walk me through how you
ended up scaling that if you had advice
that you could give 40 year old Dave
what would you tell him
I am super thrilled to be here today
because uh Dave's a legend and uh I'm
gonna I'm gonna give a little bit of an
intro from my perspective of you this is
a little scary
um and I actually wanted to take the
first like few minutes to um actually
just kind of like hype Dave and I think
it's because like on in the marketplace
of attention right now I actually still
think you're underpriced
um I still think that you are
underappreciated for the amount of value
that you provide to the audience at
large and flattery will get you
everywhere
come here
um but one of the things I wanted to hit
on it was um like I see and I'm sure you
do or your team does like there are a
lot of people who take I would you know
I'll use the term fake gurus but a lot
of people who
haven't achieved you know a 100th of the
level of success that you have that take
a lot of shots and at you and you know a
lot specifically around your views on
debt but sometimes just in general and
um you know we have a big belief that at
acquisition.com that the only people who
ever hate you um are never ahead of you
uh and I feel like that's been extremely
true and it's been tough for people to
be ahead of you in general
um but I just want to give context for
my audience
that number one uh you've been doing
this for three decades yeah a little
over you know three decades uh and your
overnight uh three decade success yeah
for real
yeah it's just in time to get old
[Laughter]
and
what I'm going to be directing the the
conversation today around is actually
around business stuff so Dave has a
zillion things on Personal Finance I
mean I think that was the you know the
wedge product that absolutely a lot of
everything
um but because our audience is
predominantly business owners I want to
focus on how the actual building of
Ramsay Solutions and kind of some of the
things that you that you learned along
the way some of the big mistakes that
you did some things that you'd go back
in time and would have done differently
um and even as you've kind of scaled the
brand so that's kind of the direction
okay that work sure okay so um
can you give a little bit of background
in terms of how Ramsay Solutions the
education business which was the first
business correct and they've all kind of
evolved together okay
um how did that come to be and then what
was your thinking around the business
model at that time and like what has it
evolved into oh
well um
all of it started uh
extremely primitive
I mean like one plus one equals
two barely you know kind of thing and uh
so like for instance we started I I went
down there's a talk radio show or talk
radio station in Nashville at the time
that was in chapter 11 bankruptcy and
there was a guy doing a bad financial
show like a Saturday Night Live skit you
know on there I went on as a guest on
the bad financial show and I didn't have
any books I just went on for fun I was
actually promoting a real estate Club I
was in and
um he said hey I hear you're helping
people with your fork with foreclosures
and helping them stop getting their car
repoed or if they're having financial
trouble over at your church are you
doing that and I said yeah I'm just kind
of doing that for fun just to help folk
it as a Ministry at the church and he
goes wow if you've got any questions
about that call up and phone rang and he
never got any phone calls he didn't know
what to do didn't even know how to put
the guy in the air and so
um he said hey come back let's do that
again because his phone never rings and
so I went I did it like two times and
then he quit and then we went down
talked to that guy that that was running
that station into letting us work for
free
and so a couple guys me and a couple
other guys went on the air uh answering
questions uh uh in a really heavy
hillbilly twang uh WWE tell you in
you're talking Nashville y'all call in I
mean it was it was nasty buddy I'm
telling you it was nasty and uh but with
information was good and the phone rang
yeah from the very first day at about
the same time I had finished writing uh
on my laptop in my living room uh on the
very first version of Windows this is
1992. uh my first book and I
self-published it carried home in the
trunk of my car got a thousand copies
and I went on the radio and said hey
I'll get my book and um some people did
and uh and the 18 months later edu to
get to your question yeah we moved the
uh card table out of my living room and
one old beat up desk from the days when
I went bankrupt and opened an office in
800 square foot month to month rent and
me and another guy another guy was gonna
Financial coaching the way I teach to do
that I was going to continue to do that
and when we launched a in April of 1994
a class on how to handle money it was
actually how to avoid bankruptcy
um and one of the lessons was on the
different types of bankruptcy one of the
lessons was on how to stop a foreclosure
if it's an FHA if it's a VA or if it's
Fannie Mae different processes to stop a
foreclosure
um and you know all these different
things and the people that came weren't
bankrupt
they were just making a lot of money and
spending it all okay so they were broke
it was all the money comes in all the
money goes out only the names are
changed to protect the innocent but they
weren't behind on their house payment
right they just were fighting with each
other in their marriage and they didn't
know how to do a budget and no one ever
told them about insurance so I took the
bankruptcy and the Foreclosure lesson
out and replaced it with a uh uh
retirement lesson and here's how
Investments work lesson uh compound
interest whoa and which is you know
still for the general public causes
their
brains to just go melt down in a
wonderful way the first time you see
compound interest right and so yeah we
that was called life after debt
um in April and uh four people came the
first night I sold three of them
so for you digital people I had a 75
conversion rate set up right but um I'm
telling you it was primitive overhead
projector bad suit you know that whole
thing and then we changed it to called
it Financial Peace University the five
months later in September six months
later
and now Financial Peace universities had
10 million people go through it and 50
000 churches have taught it unbelievable
so for
context the services that you had was
education with some level of service
kind of like holding accountable or
keeping them consistent on top of that
which the reason that I I was really
intent on talking to you was that in the
space that we're in today and obviously
the the marketplace has changed a lot
you have an education business and I
would say that the vast majority of
quote education businesses are
not perceived as legitimate
[Music]
um
how do you think you've been able to
anchor in it like it's it's very clear
that ramp Solutions is a legitimate
business obviously
um but what do you why do you think that
so many of them are not perceived that
way
um like what's the Gap what are people
missing there
I I honestly don't know I I know that um
in the financial World in general
and I think most of your listeners and
you and I agree to this that
there's a lot of us I grew up in that
world and and I'm a nerd by nature and
got a degree in finance for God's sakes
and so I in other words I thought the
way to fix everything was with the math
um
and math treats the symptom right not
the problem and what our brand
differentiator and it may be the
difference in what you're talking about
as well is that we did come to
understand that it's a behavior problem
it's personal finances 80 Behavior 20
head knowledge I've said that like I
don't know eight million times in 30
years and um but it is and the problem
with my money is the guy in my mirror if
I can get him to behave he can be skinny
and Rich and we've talked about this all
these lines these riffs that we do and
we do them over and over and over and
over and over again and but it but but
that's the differentiator that's the
thing they said oh yeah
because I mean knowing how to do a
budget is different than actually doing
one knowing how to live on lesson you
make or that you should is different
than actually doing it knowing that
eating 73 Donuts will make me fat is
different than not eating 73 Donuts
right yeah personal testimony but the um
but yeah that that stuff I I think
that's the difference and then what has
happened is that if you go through and
you do the stuff that we teach
and we've got the systems in place to
help you be held accountable to do it
and encourage you when you're struggling
and scared and hopeless
um but if you're arrogant and prideful
either way we're going to be there in
your grill uh saying we love you so much
that you need to change if you do this
stuff and you actually make the changes
due to the accountability that that
because you keep doing what you've been
doing you'll keep getting what you've
been getting so you got to change the
recipe so if you change the recipe you
have success and lives transformed
is legitimacy that gives you legitimacy
and so in in other words I don't know if
they set out to be illegitimate but they
didn't maybe they didn't have the uh the
the life wasn't actually changed you
know if I join a gym yeah and then I
don't get anything out of that I don't
have any weight loss no increased muscle
tone no
um you know increased aerobic whatever
whatever it is you're trying to
accomplish if I don't get any of that
even if it's my fault yeah it feels like
the gym is illegitimate I don't think
the Gym's necessarily are legitimate but
the results were illegitimate yeah and
so then you get labeled that way yeah
and so I hear people say Dave Ramsey
stuff doesn't work the haters right
right and uh it absolutely does not work
unless you work it yeah like I guarantee
that I can make you that personal
guarantee
shifting back to the business
um
explain to me how how the actual
products we developed over time so in
the beginning you had the education and
then you had the services that layered
on top of that was that the main thing
for like a decade or and and like walk
me through how you ended up scaling that
was that all through media but we had
the yeah okay the radio show didn't make
money for a decade
[Music]
um because I don't pay you to do radio
uh even today I don't get paid by radio
stations I have a clock split with them
and so
um and we didn't have anything to sell
when we split the clock in so we didn't
make any money so whatever we put in the
radio was lost dollars
um but it was the megaphone it was the
uh the the lead mechanism uh okay and so
we we I started doing some speaking and
then I thought hey we could do like a
little public event
in town because we were on only on the
air in one time but so we were on the
radio and announced and I think we had
um I don't know 100 people or something
come out and
um paid us like 40 bucks or something to
sit for three hours or five hours or
whatever it wasn't listening to me
Yammer in my hillbilly twang about
getting out of debt and so we had live
events started to develop we had the
little book so we had a little bit of a
publishing thing going and we had the
class itself which is a long form
It's a combination of 12-step and
curriculum so to speak
um and and and so radio publishing Live
Events those were the first and what
becomes Financial Peace University we're
the first element oh and one-on-one
coaching one-on-one counseling we called
it in those days we now call it
Financial coaching
um
so there's no confusion that we're not
licensed therapists
um because some people can't seem to
it's not clear but anyway coaching is
hard to mess that up so um yeah so we do
that and each of those things grew at
different rates and so there were
different times in the 30 years that
um
Financial Peace University was bringing
in the Lion's Share of the money and
then publishing would come up and pass
it uh Live Events has pretty much always
been a slightly profitable but really
good secondary lead Source okay so if
you come to a live event
um because you heard us on the radio
it's going down the funnel the marketing
funnel so to speak and then they might
buy Financial Peace University which is
you know a nine week commitment and a
higher you know instead of a 20 event
ticket it's eighty dollars to go through
it or whatever they so we were working
at that and there are always books on
the back table too so uh and so once
those things worked and the book then we
had a New York Times you know the book
eventually evolved and was purchased by
a publisher and became our first New
York Times bestseller
um
once that happened and then we start
doing a bunch of we start getting more
and more radio stations and doing more
and more media so instead of just doing
a little local news guy we actually with
the book tour the first time got on the
Today Show and uh and and that opened up
something then that opened up something
and then pretty much been doing New York
media for 25 years
um obviously all that's free but it's
lead generation
and so if I were to say this back to you
the radio station served as the big
megaphone to gather attention and then
point it in a direction and one of the
places you'd point it in the earlier
days was the live events which
functioned a little bit as a conversion
event for you guys from a business
perspective and then those people would
get funneled into whatever was
appropriate for their budget uh you know
either they'd buy some books or they'd
buy the curriculum or they buy the
curriculum and some 101 Council uh 101
Financial coaching
um and then that machine has been what
you've continued to spin the wheel on
and then Gathering more and more and
more media yeah we've got and we've got
more and more product mix okay I mean
we've got uh you know we ended up uh I
advertised for a stock brokerage firm
um and then when I sent the leads the
people would go over there the local
broker that they went to would tell them
to do stuff that I had just told them on
the air not today and so that didn't
work and um people are pissed off and uh
yeah and so we said well guys y'all
can't do that with the leads we send you
well you can't tell us what to do and I
said I can tell you you can't advertise
so we're not going to be on the air so
we dropped those Folk and
um
so the product Suite from there that was
the core initial product mix and then
what we did was uh we would hear about
some need that was a a similar thing but
a finger off of that so for instance a
local coach at a Catholic High School
was took my financial piece book and
started teaching his seniors because
they needed to know about personal
finance with and then call me up and
goes hey I hope you don't mind I'm like
well I don't mind and I'm kind of
complicated but let's work together on
this let me so I went over and spoke to
him a couple times our sweet kids and
he's a great guy to Greg Carson he's a
friend of this day that was and we ended
up out of that developing a high school
curriculum that's now been taught in 48
percent of the high schools six and a
half million kids have been through it
and so um you know that was again
another product line and the edge
Solutions is another department if you
will inside of Ramsey today and pretty
substantial revenues for high school
college and even Middle School
curriculum
and and then uh you know Corporate
America says okay we'd like for our
employees to get this stuff so we take a
modified version of the Financial Peace
University that doesn't have as much of
the bible stuff in it
um and we have to not violate
um some HR rules and stuff so we had to
change some to make a little more
vanilla on different things and uh it's
called smart dollar and gosh man watch I
don't know 10 000 companies have now
taught it and including big ones like
U-Haul and uh uh Costco all of their
employees have gone through it so that's
a whole other product line but it's you
know there so the brand Suite or the
product Suite continues to evolve uh as
we look at different things where we can
serve uh we took over all the publishing
so we do all our books now uh
self-published have for about a decade
how do you think about spinning out new
products like what to do versus like
because there's obviously focus in a
business right you have limited time and
resources like how do you say this is
going to be something we're going to
just partner with someone on or this is
something we're going to bring in house
and actually own entire really or just
not do it all and ignore and just let
somebody make some extra cash on it and
we just don't worry about it yeah um
well one thing we don't do is we don't
um we have made a conscious
philosophical decision to not sell
Financial products so we don't sell
insurance we don't sell Investments we
don't sell real estate we endorse people
that do but they don't work for us
they're advertisers of shorts endorse in
our Ramsey trusted is what it falls
under that brand so some of them are
have ads on the podcast some of them we
say go to the website and fill out form
you find the realtor we recommend in
your area this Ramsay trusted that kind
of thing and so that way when I'm giving
real estate advice someone doesn't say
oh he's just trying to get us to do that
now they still say he's trying to just
get us to be a real estate lead but
that's a different thing he's trying to
sell me a house or he's trying to sell
me a mutual fund we don't endorse
particular mutual funds uh and we don't
um sell Investments like that so you
can't say the reason Dave does insurance
is because or says term by term
insurances because he owns a term
insurance firm because I don't and you
know one of the lies out there floating
around is I own half of Churchill
Mortgage which I don't own a dime of
it'd been nice if I had and they've done
really well and I don't I don't have for
some of Xander insurance or both
advertisers been with me 26 27 years
consecutively and
um but I don't own any of those they're
just they're they're friends of mine but
I'm doing business with them for three
decades and they do really well and they
do a great job for a listener and so
those are media Partnerships they're
sponsors that's all they are I mean
they're just advertisers on the on the
original talk radio show which is now
like you guys I mean your podcast and
YouTubes and tick tocks and everything
everything yeah
what have been some of the major
beliefs that you had to break along the
journey from and if so what's what's top
line revenue today across all of the
portfolio I'm calling portfolio I'm
using my own language but across Ramsay
Solutions Ramsay Solutions uh revs will
be a little over 300 million this year
okay so for context in terms of size
here for my audience 300 a lot uh
so what what were some of the because
you know a lot of businesses grow at
least in my observation of businesses is
they're they're step Wise It's they'll
they'll grow they'll grow and they'll
hit something and then they stay there
until they figure out whatever that
thing was and then they go super fast
again and then they hit another wall and
they keep going what have been some of
the you know two or three major pivot
Points in the business in terms of your
lessons or beliefs that you had to
reshape that allowed you to break
through to new levels of growth
you know I think because the product
line was so uh diverse
um the
different ones of those were stepping at
different times and it caused our actual
Revenue growth to not stair step but it
could be fairly smooth interesting on a
curve got it um but like you know if we
went for instance to Financial Peace
University it went through different
seasons where it would go and then it
would stop and it would just sit you
know and we're kind of in one of those
stop and sip modes now because we're
making this transition uh from being
primarily Church distributed okay uh
because churches aren't teaching classes
like that in this current environment as
much as they used to yeah and so we've
got to have a more direct consumer uh
digital uh distribution methodology and
we're discovering that right now so it's
plateaued right now got it Financial
University is awesome it's excellent but
it's but from a business Revenue
perspective business model it's you know
it's big spike would have been the
mid-2000s okay I mean it made it went
crazy up and it was kind of like the 800
pound gorilla revenue-wise inside the
building and then it moved over to the
other thing so uh what are the your
question is not the stair step a
question your question was uh what are
some Milestones along the way like
lessons you had the shift that allowed
you to be an entrepreneur that could get
to I mean 10 I mean do you remember when
you hit your first 10 million years yeah
first 30 in your first hundred and your
first you know any any big changes that
happen in you as a person that that you
can denote and say I learned this and
this is why we were able to break
through that yeah I I figured out
um fairly early
that
um that organizations are not going to
outgrow
the character and uh intellectual
capacity of their leadership
primarily me
and so if I'm if I remain dumb in some
of the areas I'm dumb in then we're not
going to be at 600 million you know I've
got a uh or somebody else will be doing
it and if they remain dumb they can't
you just can't do it I mean there's
stuff you don't know and so I was uh I
grew up in a real estate household Mom
and Daddy were in residential real
estate business and so I've been selling
my whole life straight commission for me
but self-employment is a
H isn't my DNA I don't know how to think
about working for someone uh and some
and when you grow up in that world you
know you learn to kill it and drag it
home because you ain't got anything to
eat if you don't kill something to drag
at home and so
um very tactical and so I couldn't Spell
strategic when we started and we got
large enough that we started hiring
these things called mbas and these
people that actually had and uh now over
the years I've got a ton of mbas on the
team and I love the NBA programs most of
them that are out there they do a really
good job of teaching but one of the
things I learned almost universally
about mbas they are heavily steeped in
strategic thought
and so uh the mbas on our team and me
about uh 20 years ago made a really good
trade
um they taught me how to think
strategically because I didn't know how
and I taught them how to work
so it was a good trade
and so would you say that basically them
coming in and talking strategy was a
like a big unlock in terms of growth
critical thinking skills I the way you
solve a business problem how do you you
know I would just go in there and go
okay the answer is activity just go run
into the wall enough times and the wall
will fall down meanwhile the NBA
standing over the side going hey Dave
over here there's a door yeah I could
just walk around really I mean you don't
have to run in the stupid wall this is
dumb and so uh because they're looking
down on the maze yeah the Labyrinth and
can see the way through and I'm just
going just get after it just get in
there and hustle you know and you need
to have both you have the energy of the
hustle and grind and the uh because when
in doubt activity is the answer but um
unfocused unplanned activity is um not
always fun it causes pain sometimes too
so we're much better at uh well my
friend Jim Collins calls calibrated
cannonballs now than just firing
cannonballs
which
from a branding perspective because I
think you've developed a really strong
brand what are what are some of the
deliberate decisions you've had to make
to associate with versus not associating
with
in order to continue to strengthen the
brand expand the media because I would
imagine like in the flywheel that is
Ramsey Solutions the media is a huge
part of that and so like what has been
one of the big things that kept that
wheel spinning and expanding compared to
the many other people who try to to top
you I mean even the people who try and
get more audience more earballs yeah
I uh I don't know we discovered I don't
know how we figured it out it was
accidental I guess it was people getting
pissed at us in the early days we you
know like we would endorse something on
the radio just local T local radio
station and you know go to such and such
a car lot well somebody go over there
and they go the guy tried to screw me
Dave he'd call me up on the air or call
me up at my house you know find me in
the mall the guy you sent me to is a dad
gum crook Ramsay and so now I can't
trust you yeah and um
and I would lose the advertiser because
I would have to cancel them because I
was ashamed yeah of them and uh so
somewhere along the doing stupid stuff
like not vetting who we're going to
associate our brand with uh instead of
just buying it just oh we were so happy
we had an ad sold you know the middle of
Revenue my God and then you figure out
that doesn't play well because you're
destroying your credibility with the
market we figured out we were a trust
brand
and radio endorsement taught us to be
trustworthy worthy of trust and uh so
we're very careful uh as a matter of
fact just a few minutes ago I came out
of a meeting where I turned down two
potential advertisers and the sales team
said we think we need to turn these down
but before we do it's a lot of money we
need to uh ask you and I said yeah that
that guy if we put that guy on he's
gonna it's gonna cause our audience is
not no that's not so would you send your
sister there would you send your mom
there would you send your friend that
you play softball with uh you know would
you send them over there and if they
don't pass that acid test we don't put
them on the air so if I won't really buy
it or I don't really believe someone
should buy it for their own good um I
mean like 100 of the things we advertise
I don't necessarily buy personally in my
stage of life but I'm not the market for
them either so um but but I do believe
in them and I believe they're good for
you and um sometimes we mess that up
we've endorsed things we shouldn't have
endorsed in the early days even I mean
it's it's uh
uh in the last few years I've had a
really disastrous one that was a mess
and it's caused me all kinds of problems
but um you know initially started out
good and then turned bad and we didn't
we didn't cut them off fast enough uh
and it's our fault for not cutting them
up but we weren't doing it for money we
were trying to help people yeah and so
it's a trust brand and so no single
relationship Advertiser endorsement is
uh it could not possibly give you enough
Revenue in our world yeah to offset the
damage it will do if they don't take
care of the customer yeah because people
all we've got is trust and if they don't
trust us for that they also aren't going
to trust us when we tell them to get out
of debt yeah they're also not going to
trust us when we tell them hey this is
going to affect your marriage you know
the advice we give is no longer
trustworthy if the endorsement is not
trustworthy so the whole stinking thing
ends up revolving around this word and
uh so we spend a lot of time discussing
and vetting and uh cheeseclothing the
whole it's a mess but yeah it's it's
okay it's worth the effort
I agree I'm with you on that and I mean
I think that you know at acquisition.com
we try to do the the same kind of
approach which is like how can we be as
trustworthy as humanly possible because
you know we do Equity deals and so yeah
we have a huge vetting process and you
know 99.99 of the audience I have will
never do business with me but
I still need to treat you know everyone
so that the reputation which compounds
is based on trust so that we can do
deals and just to be very uh uh
transparent it um
it's emotional for me and most people in
this building
when that doesn't go right yeah when we
mess that up somehow because we our
intent is to never mess that up and when
it gets messed up it hurts our feelings
more than it does anybody's
mental mind gave me this quote you might
like it he said never risk the empire
for a pot of gold there it is that's a
great one I love it
So speaking of pots of gold so 300
million is where you're at right now
what do you see as the as the next thing
to get you know Ramsay solutions to 600
million like you were saying earlier
like what's the what's the path forward
there like what do you see is the
Strategic opportunity what are you
investing in right now
um
well
we're seeing an explosion uh with our
every dollar app for one thing it's um
it uh with minimal effort honestly has
caught fire so we're gonna pour a little
more gases on that while we're at it
we're gonna put some effort into it
since it's working and uh we do think
that Financial Peace University is going
to stair step again we've got to finish
we've got to find that
um methodology for delivering those
age-old principles in a new in a new way
we are a platform and delivery agnostic
I don't care how we get it to you but we
got to get it to you and it's not and
efficiently with the least friction
possible so people actually do this
stuff and so that that's there um
uh some things are going are
logistically have uh in the last say 20
of the 30 years have be not they didn't
shrink they grew but they don't have the
logistical ability to grow uh Revenue
wise as much and an example That'd Be
Live Events there's only so much of that
you can do and it doesn't it doesn't
hockey stick right you because you you
have the bottleneck actual bodies on a
stage yeah and bodies to set the stage
up and that kind of stuff and number of
cities you can actually draw a crowd in
and that kind of thing so
um the only way you can hockey stick
that thing would be to run the prices
where they were just not for the average
guy and our whole thing we do is for the
average guy so
um so that's gonna if they ever if it
stays the same or grows at five percent
and something else grew up fifty percent
it's going to get to be a smaller and
smaller piece of the pie right
mathematically but still not be
something we're ashamed of we love Live
Events and not we're one of the biggest
event companies in America we do it
great Live Events but uh but it's gonna
end up that one's not probably going to
be the answer
um unless now streaming could
um it would have to monetize for the
first time but I suck on monetization
but uh but it's good at getting
information out there uh so I I I
um we don't see hardcover books as being
something that's going to hockey stick
uh in the coming years but I do think
they're going to continue to be a a
valid part of the mix
um so it's probably more a digital
application and delivery because it's
the easiest to scale and lowest cost of
goods
and um and it uh more easily iterates
than anything analog
and uh the rate of change
uh has exponentially increased in 30
years it used what used to would take us
five years to see unfold in the
marketplace is unfolding in five or ten
weeks right now yeah and um how fast uh
entire social media platforms become
irrelevant is is kind of amazing
and uh so you know betting the whole
thing on one delivery mechanism uh Dom
and so
um
ah
in my mind anyway but yeah so
I think whatever it is is gonna like an
app like a budgeting app or a delivery
digitally of FPU or delivery digitally
of our entree leadership which is our
small business uh teaching and coaching
uh you only have so many
physical coaches for small business guys
right and uh that's got a limiting
factor do I want 3 000 of those people
in the building no I really don't yeah
I'd rather figure out another way to
help you folk out there and that that is
um not as Manpower hungry so when you
said the every dollar app just kind of
like took off is that like a micro
example of how product iteration works
for you is like let's throw something
together let's see how it works and then
if it starts taking off
disproportionately to like the effort
you say okay now we're going to invest
more resources in it yeah we put a huge
amount of effort into building it and
launching the initial yeah um it was a
major initiative and a push and then it
kind of you know it was had a good
growth rate but it really wasn't but
something shifted in the marketplace I
mean
later in the last four or five months
okay uh and the way the consumer uh is
viscerally responding to the word budget
uh differently than they were certainly
uh 10 years ago but probably even 10
months ago and so when we develop things
so we're gonna you know we've always
iterated it we've always updated it
we've always made it better every time
and all that kind of stuff but um there
just seems to be uh some
attention that we didn't cause so why
not join the parade yeah right I think
probably someone that's the the macro
economic environment has changed a
little bit in the last you know in that
period of time people are probably
feeling the need for a budget
and it might be that I mean I think the
product the original launch on it was uh
it's probably coming up on 10 years you
know so okay in the um you know the the
number of people that are walking around
adults that have have uh never lived in
a world that wasn't a smartphone world
is much larger than it was 10 years ago
yeah and so the marketplace has shifted
in that regard with the the the iPhone
the uh
um whatever whatever smartphone is
native to a much larger percentage of
the population than it was uh when it
was launched so we may just be seeing
that demographic shift and then
um they're aging into it yeah because
they you know that age group I mean if
you're 28 you you wouldn't ever think of
doing a budget on paper
it would not occur to you that that no
more than you would hand write a letter
in cursive you know I mean it's just
absurd so but you know when I started
all this that wasn't neither one of
those was that unusual right
So speaking of of
the app in particular as is a an
increasingly large part of the pie
um how does it measure compared to the
other pieces like just by percentage
you've got the events you've got the
education you've got Entre leadership
you've got the app you've got the Live
Events
um like how how do how do those divide
up in terms of uh like size for Ramsay
Solutions the Ramsey trusted items which
includes National advertisers and uh the
whole uh smart Victor Pros all the
endorse all the people we endorse for
um investing all the real estate agents
although there's about eight thousand
nine thousand different uh people that
we endorse in different areas tax really
all that tax and um real estate and
investing uh through Ramsey trusted and
then you've got a singular National
Advertiser like a church or mortgage for
mortgages that kind of all that falls
under Ramsay trusted so that's a lot
under there but uh the the uh the
national uh associations plus the
Strategic alliances we call them the the
what used to be called the ELP program
probably amounts to 40 percent of the
revenue really
um and so
not
let are not putting on back to our
earlier conversation not putting on one
that's bad yeah is a big deal there yeah
because you're going to mess up the
whole thing you know you're going to
mess up the Empire with that singular
bad pot of gold and so we have to you
know to be a real estate agent in Ramsey
trusted you really are we're really
going to do the stuff we tell you do or
we're really not gonna let you in there
I mean it's a big deal you know and so
because we love you and we love our
customers and we want everybody to have
a Little Love Fest we don't need anybody
pissed off so yeah you're really going
to do this stuff so that's uh uh
probably uh I think it's probably saying
about 40 percent of the revs right now
but that's half that had gun building
too in terms of the 1100 people that
work here uh entree leadership is
probably
uh 15 uh you know something like that uh
Financial Peace University is probably
15 percent
um you know uh every dollar is
10 maybe or less it's less than 10
percent
um but they know they just kind of fall
out like that publishing and Live Events
together not that huge Revenue but again
they're almost they're like almost yeah
they're almost lead Gathering yeah
things so um
I'm trying to think what else falling in
that p l but just something like that
there's the big ones yeah that's big
rocks how do you think about
reallocating or reinvesting Capital
within the business versus taking it out
of the business
as an owner um
well we we uh don't randomly if we have
something we can I can get more Roi
here
on something that we have a high belief
in than I could anywhere else I mean
certainly on mutual funds are real
estate right I mean I love mutual funds
in real estate but I mean I can get a
thousand percent ROI on launching a
product yeah and I can't even approach
that on this other stuff so I would
rather deploy the capital here but I
don't need to deploy it stupidly so
um
when in doubt uh we take it home and we
doubt take it out yeah yeah that's it
and plug it into the you know plug it in
the generosity and plug it into some
more real estate or mutual funds
so
um I'm gonna I'm gonna pivot a little
bit on the on the investing side because
I wanted to give you uh something that
you might not know but you did a a
podcast with graham Stefan and he was so
much fun he's a great guy yeah Grandma's
Graham's a nice guy he's done he's done
a great job too on his stuff man yeah
he's fought in your Footsteps in a lot
of ways well he no he's he's different
but I mean he's doing he's good he's we
like him yeah Graham's a good dude and
he showed you his investment uh
portfolio oh yeah that's like a thing he
does when he has people on I'm like I
don't know Graham I don't know if I'm
qualified to help you with that yeah you
said something to him that massively
changed the direction of how we invested
just so you know yeah well so I just
wanted to share that with you so I think
you had said loosely
well before I look at this if this were
your brain or your knowledge or your
experiences what percentage of this pie
would you say is real estate versus
stocks versus anything else and he said
well
because he had asked you do you think
I'm over indexed on real estate
but when you asked him the question he
said well I mean I guess probably 85 of
my knowledge is around real estate and I
think his portfolio kind of reflected
that you're like well then that's a
perfect mix for you and for me as we
were coming out of the of our liquidity
event we'd probably taken about 40
million home before that wow good for
you that's awesome it's not 300. the 300
is gross dude you know the difference in
Gross in that and
um but anyways and so I had during while
I was growing the business I I basically
just didn't really invest at all I mean
I just put it in indexes and was like
I'll deal with it later
um and then we had the included event
and I had I talked to probably every guy
that I know was who was richer than me
and was like what should I do with all
this and the answers that I got were as
different as there are people under the
sun yep which left me more confused than
anything and so the reason that that
little piece of advice that you gave to
Graham was so meaningful for me was that
it was personalized because everybody
told me what they did and what had
worked for them but you know one of the
guys I asked was like oh take all that
and buy one huge building and I was like
I don't know anything about I was like I
really I don't want to risk everything
on one building he's like well I've been
doing this 30 years like that's what you
should do it's like
I'm gonna mess this up
that scares the crap out of me yeah yeah
tenants and termites and toilets and all
that stuff I have no idea any of that
stuff works right
and so when I thought back on when I
looked at that pie and thought okay well
what's my knowledge base it was like
it's all business everything I've done
has been business and all the money I've
made has been business and so
um I showed that clip to Layla my wife
and I was like I think I think this is
what we should do I think we should just
stick to business and just buy
businesses and grow them and so I love
it that's what we did with
acquisition.com wow good for you that's
a great wow but that little piece of
advice changed the direction of how I
mean how we allocate all of our assets
and what we do because it's funny
because if I was going to write a five
million check into a building I I got
like you know three or four deals that
were around that size in terms of check
size and um I'd get all the way to the
end and I was like I don't know what
[Applause]
trusting that this is a good deal like I
had the Excel sheet and the you know
projector returns all the stuff and I
was like I don't feel good about this
because I don't know when on the flip
side if I'm going to write a five
million check into a business
I feel fine about it because I'm like oh
I know how like I know I've I don't know
everything obviously it's sure it's your
sandbox right yeah and so um anyways
that's beautiful I love that that's what
what happened was we had a product that
we called
wealth coach for a little while and uh
we ended up doing these very small but I
don't know we charged more than we ever
charged like a thousand bucks or
something we always charge 20 bucks so
to come to those little seminars and we
ended up talking to these people they
were millionaires or five million and 10
million and I I kept asking them okay
what do you put money into because
they're they've actually done it they
had money like you've actually done it
you have money and so it's not someone
with a theory yeah on Tick Tock you know
and so um
what I kept hearing from them was this
array of all kinds of different things
so I couldn't it wasn't the answer to
the question wasn't a certain investment
made them Rich what it was was they put
money and stuff they knew yeah and I
mean one guy was a car dealer and he had
a massive classic car collection which
for an ego driven person is a horrible
idea right but because because you can
lose your butting in any kind of
collectible yeah but for somebody that
is in the car business and his gr his
grandfather had a dealership and he his
father had a dealership and he had he he
knows that loves it yeah he goes out in
the garage and pets the cars I mean you
know say guess what he's making that
portfolio seriously gave him a great
return now do I recommend to the general
public go get a cart no no put money in
stuff you understand and you love
and don't put money in stuff because it
sounds fancy
um or somebody you know it sounds
sophisticated because there's something
that happens when you get money you
think that everybody that has money is
sophisticated about their investing and
what I figured out was almost no one is
yeah they're very primitive I mean a lot
of people I talked to were farmers and
we went throughout lots of land they got
dirt man that's it just dirt and it
doesn't even I mean they don't even
necessarily plant it but they just buy
dirt and one guy at 8 000 Acres of dirt
you know and I'm like in Kansas you know
I'm like golly I wouldn't need more good
I don't know anything about that kind of
dirt I like real estate but that would
scare me to death yeah but for him it
was the most comfortable natural thing
in the world to your point and so I just
learned that put money in stuff you love
and you understand don't put money and
stuff because it sounds sophisticated
because you're getting ready to lose
your butt because you're trusting some
guy who doesn't have any money who's
trying to sell you something and
um driving a bad car and um so yeah uh
we'll name the bad car but anyways yeah
I mean that that's that's where that
came from it's just anecdotally
hanging out with those folks and
researching it and it gave me peace
because I was starting to make bank for
the first time and I'm like I need to be
like doing double backflip limited
family Partnerships or some kind of crap
I don't even know what they are but I
probably ought to be doing one if I'm
making this kind of money and and then I
and you talk to a guy and he's like yeah
you ought to do a double backflip with a
Twist and I'm like yeah yeah but get
right up to it and I'm going you know I
don't half understand no I think I'd
rather just bury it in the backyard than
that because at least I know where it is
you know yeah it's funny though because
even with the dirt example um there's a
guy who his entire investment strategy
explained an interview he's like you
guys are going to be bored about what
we're gonna do for the next 55 minutes
because I can explain it in five and
we're like and I you know I'm listening
I'm like okay here you know here's it
he's like okay so what I do is I find a
city
and I find the main street because
usually there's a main street that goes
through the middle of the states the
oldest street whatever it's like and
then I take a ruler and I go out 30
miles he's like and then I buy all that
land he's like and then I wait 20 years
I love this guy
and what are the any questions yeah he's
like so what do you want to do with the
rest of our time together
they're like so how do you hatch he's
like oh buy it in cash because you can't
you know can't take loans on land and uh
yeah that's that's what I do and we've
been doing that for many many many I had
dinner with a guy the other night that a
two billion dollar net worth and he's
second gen but his dad was dirt doing
dirt not unlike what your friend was
doing and
um then he couldn't get the bank to do
the deal he was borrowing money to do
the dirt and so he bought the bank
it was a little Hometown Bank and they
screwed with him and so he bought it and
he's like okay now they'll behave and
um then he started making money on the
bank and got in and got to figure out
how bank and and now they own like 15 or
20 000 Acres three wineries around the
world and a whole bunch of banks a bunch
of Community Banks and they and their
billion multi-billionaires and so yeah
but it started from that and they don't
really do anything else the wineries are
more of a fun project I don't I think
they know what they're doing with those
probably the way he was talking he knew
wine and
um the uh but the uh but he knows Banks
he knows dirt and that's where all their
money is yeah and they're they're not
Diversified for having as much billions
with an S you know I mean it's it's
interesting those kind of people are
enthralling to me and it's interesting
because most of the the billionaires
that I have looked at they usually make
their money in one or two vehicles that
they know exceedingly well where they
feel like they have an unfair advantage
and like they they get there not because
there's a Marketplace Advantage but
because they have an information
Advantage they know it better exactly
exactly and
if you go through the Forbes 400 I think
it's 67 last time I looked or first gen
they're all billionaires now you don't
qualify if you don't have a b and um
they're first gen and I think
I looked at them
of the first Gins uh it was 90 something
percent were business driven so it was
Michael Dell you know Bill Gates um
Hobby Lobby David Green
um Chick-fil-A sure Kathy
um you know and so they started a
business and it led to either they took
it public or they just monetized the
crud out of it and it just has a value
Marketplace valuation Oprah yeah you
know
um
but you know the the secret of Oprah's
wealth is not her Celebrity Status it's
the Empire she built under the Celebrity
Status and so uh you know you go down
those things like that and you go okay
you can get to one to five million
dollar net worth with your 401k and your
paid off home yeah but you you know
mathematically impossible to get to a
billion in your 401k it's not possible
to do it yeah so you got to do there's
other strategies to be involved if
you're going to do that
so I wanted to take a quick second
because uh it would be hard for me to to
talk Dave Ramsey without talking about
debt and um a lot of people so in my
audience
um I'm kind of dead agnostic I don't
talk much about it um but a lot of
people don't know that I actually have
no debt either and so everything I
bought to this point in my life has been
cash now I'm not against that I just
kind of talk about uh you know when I
get right at the edge or something I
just I end up not doing it
um it's been that way with most kind of
loan things in general and I read uh
Financial or Total Money Makeover
um
years ago and you have this line in
there about debt that was I'm going to
try and say it back to you as I
understood it because there's there's
obviously the biblical component but for
everyone who might not believe in that
um I wanted to give at least my rap my
rational understanding of how you see it
which is that debt introduces risk and
risk when it when compounded over a long
enough time Horizon no matter how big a
number you acquire any number multiplied
by zero is still zero and so if you know
that you're going to be playing this
game for a very long time even a small
amount of risk when you're going 200
miles an hour you can flip the car
that was my understanding of how you saw
debt
is that accurate that's that's how I I
saw it or at least I interpreted your
view on debt now that line is actually
from Warren Buffett um he uh and one of
his his famous annual reports they're
they're very cheeky and fun to read and
especially the opening paragraphs or so
in one of those he was talking about you
know down year like 08
um you know we soon discover that
Leverage is not always your friend yeah
those of us that could do math realize
that any number multiplied by zero is
going to equal zero yeah and that does
that for you so yeah it's um again
having grown up in the real estate
business one thing you're going to do in
the real estate business when I was
growing up if you said I'm going to be a
real estate investor they took you to
the hospital they took out your risk
meter and they broke it with a hammer
and they put it back in you're not
allowed to perceive risk if you're going
to be a real estate guy because and
because it's ever it's a glass half full
or Eternal optimists everything's going
to work out because real estate's always
awesome it's the most awesomeness um
parade you can't mess this up the
renters will pay your rent oh God that
or pay your mortgage you how can you
mess this up and you know so if if a
little bit of Leverage is is good then a
lot of Leverage is amazing and uh and
that's how I went broke yeah you know I
leveraged up to my eyeballs on had a
bunch of short-term notes in the bank
called to the unthinkable and call my
notes when they got sold to another bank
and they saw a 26 year old kid owed him
a million two on the 90-day notes doing
flips this was before chip and Joanna
told us how to do it and so and do a
flip oh my God and we didn't have HG to
channel to tell us how to fix up a house
I without cable TV I did this stuff and
so
um
yeah so that's where it came from and
then what happened to me because I lost
everything following the
borrow all you can because it works plan
um I had to stop
and go uh I think I've got a bad set of
rules the Playbook I've got sucks I keep
losing and and my kids are getting
skinny I mean this is not working so
when I did that the first as you said
the first uh door I went through was I
was I had just become a Christian and so
I started studying the Bible and so for
my as a matter of faith I started
reading scriptures and all the
scriptures say negative things about
that it doesn't say it's a sin they say
you're going to hell but it's stuff like
the borrower slave to the lender you're
a fool if you co-sign I mean it says
these things in scripture and then you
talk to old rich people and they go well
you stay out of that boy you know and
okay that's kind of Grandma gods and
Grandma's ways of doing it so what did I
miss in Academia when I fell in love
with leverage from an academic Viewpoint
because how is it it's incongruent to me
that if this book of wisdom and these
people that are long in the tooth with
gray hair
that have proof social proof they've got
money and they kept it are all saying
avoid debt what is it that we're missing
in academic land with my intellect so
spiritual social proof now I got to
solve it intellectually and what I ended
up doing I ended up speaking at uh
Vanderbilt to a group of mbas early in
my career and it it forced me to because
I knew I was going to go in there and
get tackled right because they're going
to go
you're primitive you believe the
Bible you know you don't know anything
and you don't know how to do math and I
know I know how to do math as a matter
of fact it's about all I know how to do
I'm a math guy so what I figured out was
was that in business debt
or real estate debt business is not
publicly traded
um
no one
includes all the math mm-hmm they leave
out a risk factor associated with that
mathematically and so we look at a very
inaccurate and primitive measure of
Leverage and so if I can borrow this
money at two percent and I can invest it
at eight
why am I not making six well a you left
out inflation B you left out taxes but
aside from that
um and that's pretty basic because this
is the argument it's that it is that the
argument is that primitive right but you
did not adjust for the risk you took on
because I think we can all agree if you
have a business that's doing 10 million
Top Line and you've got uh 12 million
dollars in debt you have a lot more risk
than if you had two million dollars in
debt and even two million dollars is
more risk than if you had zero debt we
can agree that debt is equal to risk and
if we can agree to that then we ought to
be able to assign if we're going to
really get down in the analytical jungle
we can assign a mathematical formula
that well Tada there is one it already
exists we just never applied it in that
in the investment World they teach us to
adjust you don't compare an aggressive
growth stock mutual fund that has a high
peaks and valleys on the graph volatile
with a growth and income fund which has
almost no Peaks and valleys so a growth
and income fund may have a beta of a 0.8
meaning it is only 80 percent as risky
as the s p
when you're comparing it to an
aggressive growth stock mutual fund that
might have a 2.0 meaning it's twice as
volatile risky and so in that world
we're taught I mean one of the first
things you've learned doing financial
analysis in that world is the bet you
use the beta as an inverse in the math
and you and you flip it on its head and
you multiply it through and you adjust
for risk mathematically so that you can
then say after you adjust for the
volatility the 0.8 versus the 2.0 versus
the s p is a 1.0 it's your Baseline when
you adjust for that risk uh the
perceived Return of the aggressive
growth stock mutual fund at 20 ready to
return where the other one's making 11.2
it goes away it neutralizes it and you
might end up with with a risk adjusted
that 11.2 will come up and the 20 will
come down yeah risk adjusted and then
you can actually compare apples to
apples but you've risk adjusted for the
volatility and mathematically we don't
do that in business right we just go I
won't buy bulldozer let's go get 50 000
at the bank yeah and I think I can do it
I think we can push some dirt and that
that is your risk analysis well kiss my
butt that is dumb okay and and people do
that all the time and so what I
determined was is that I'm going to go
if you want to compare two dry cleaners
you know one has debt one doesn't I've
got a risk adjust for that
mathematically and you have to apply a
beta formula that I present that to this
group of mbas and they're all sitting
there with their jaws on their lap going
uh no one ever said that and I said it's
because it's never been said no one no
one does it in the world no one no
you're not trained this way you're
trained that way in only one bucket of
Finance all the other buckets of Finance
zero real estate people do this
zero
none they do not analyze risk and so if
you take risk out then unlimited
leverage right is logical but if you say
unlimited leverage they go oh not quite
maybe 80 maybe a 70 maybe a LTV right
and uh you know but if you push them up
to the edge they can actually feel it a
little bit because they there's a
remnant of a risk meter in there but it
just doesn't function anymore
that's where that came from oh I love it
probably more than you want it but yeah
no no I wanted to uh to kind of hear
your take on it and uh because obviously
you know in the business acquisition
world there's also debt that's that's
factored in now we've done all all cash
deals um up to this point
um but I wanted to just kind of hear
your take on it uh and I I quit Warren
Buffett a lot he's a big yeah but even
though even in the public of traded
realm you know if you we were taught and
and still taught
bonds or debt and so if you're looking
at a company with publicly traded stock
it has a heavy Bond weight yeah you
discount the pde you don't compare that
stock Apples to Apples where the company
has no bond rate zero bonds that's zero
then I bank that then on short-term debt
they're sitting over there debt free you
you would give them some benefit on
their stock analysis mathematically
we're taught to do that but again it
does not transfer from the mutual fund
world or the publicly traded world
to the real estate world or the small
business World small business uh
privately held businesses don't even I
mean I know people that do you know do
have a billion dollar Top Line and
honestly they don't even look at they
just they just some a lot of them just
don't borrow money they don't even know
why they don't borrow money they just
don't borrow money because somebody told
them to one time and they go I like not
being in debt I could sleep better and
that's their entire analysis you know uh
me I've got analysis and I can do the
country boy thing too and say I just
sleep better bring on a pandemic I got
cash yeah I
I'll I'll bring us home because I had a
and I could talk to you all day um and I
appreciate you taking the time to to you
know talk to me and the audience the
game I've been honored it's fun fun
conversation if you had advice that you
could and I'll keep it specific to
business advice
um that you could give 40 year old Dave
would you tell him
then that like you know now that you
didn't know them
play incremental long ball don't look
for the home run
um
I keep waiting for somebody to call me
and for this to get easy
one phone call and it's all over and
it's like oh now I don't have to think
about it anymore someone else is gonna
do it for me it's all automatic it's
never going to be automatic it's never
going to be easy it's
um it's a hustle and grind it's a claw
you're going to make a bazillion
mistakes make mistakes that are
experiments that you survive you put out
a hypothesis you survive the experiment
to live another day to have another
experiment put out another hypothesis
another product that fails another idea
that fails and our failures at Ramsey
are not in New in number and in money
are way greater than our successes the
only thing is we survive them a we
didn't have debt and B we never bet the
farm on one horse and so from a
diversification standpoint we never
pushed all the chips to the middle of
the table on one hand
and so we're not looking for the
singular home run we're looking to
survive and fight another day and keep
iterating and the the
culmination of that the accumulated
value of those iterations are what we
call the gleaming mountain of success
which turns out as a pile of garbage and
mistakes that you're just standing on
rather than laying under it
I love that uh one of the things that we
have in our community is a 100 gold 100
golden BBS no silver bullets there you
go that's one that's exactly you know
you beat me that's much better than mine
I would have just gone with that you
know it's the same thing I keep waiting
on the phone call but uh I mean it's
never I've had a couple of my thoughts
yet and then I was um found out they
were just people and they weren't Magic
well it's funny because I joke with our
community because a lot of my community
small business owners you know probably
you know from a hundred thousand dollars
a year to 100 million dollars a year is
probably like the broad brush stroke of
the people who are listening to this
um
and the biggest thing a lot of them
suffer from is you know shiny object
syndrome is that yeah as soon as
something starts to get hard something
new looks easy and so they jump from the
hard thing to the easy thing and really
it's just uninformed optimism and then
they get into it and then they have
informed pessimism
that's beautiful that's beautiful yeah I
mean by the time it shines you're late
you're late it's too late
I mean if you think Tick Tock is new
you're late yeah it's already not new
it may have already turned down and we
while we were talking right now
well I mean if if we have a second let
me know um in terms of how because
you've survived survived a strong word
uh you've thrived uh platform agnostic
you know you have you I mean you were in
radio you've done live stuff but then I
see YouTube clips uh of your show
pumping out every day you guys crush it
on YouTube and you do it kind of your
way
um how have you thought about navigating
platforms as they come and go and how
you kind of reinvest in where where are
we going to make a bet and say okay
we're going to start expending resources
here or is it just if there's attention
we'll go there like how do you think
through that
uh we try to go there and then we expend
resources based on uh results and so
um the YouTube shorts that we've been
pumping out is only about a year and a
half old and uh we're getting incredible
results uh but we're getting results on
those as an example
um we don't view those as life
transformation items okay we view them
as lead magnets to lead you to the
long-form show to Financial Peace
University to a book which are life
transformation items so
um they're um free advertisements that
cause people to get in get a little
sample you get a little old lady
standing in Costco with a sample biscuit
right and so you get a little sample and
um
uh get a little sample biscuit and then
you may go buy the whole thing in the
freezer uh and but so we
I would not do in other words our
philosophy on like changing lives is
while we're here we would not only do
YouTube shorts because they don't change
lives um
okay we would not only do uh the new
long-form tick tock six minutes seven
minutes we would not only do that uh
because it won't change a life
um and so it's got to lead us somewhere
and based on its response on doing that
or just general activity around whatever
the item is whether it's a long form or
short form uh it is we're gonna we're
gonna pour gas on where we're seeing
stuff work and you know so we don't you
know for the last two years we put uh
little to no effort in growing Twitter
[Music]
um
Tucker Carlson might change that
it may become a broadcast medium and uh
so we'll probably be on Twitter next
week well Elon is definitely yeah
pushing Elon and he's gonna but I mean
they're if it's not going to just be a
uh a cauldron for trolls uh then
um and it's actually going to put out
some positive information uh in a way
that is consumable and could grow and if
if Elon proves that with Tucker I mean
we'll jump in there and try it right now
and all that is we're not going to put a
ton of money on it or uh resources or
bandwidth on it but we're I this week we
were discussing we're probably gonna try
it and uh tuck what Tucker's doing and
what elon's doing with Tucker and with
that whole idea of broadcasting there
um because Facebook live is didn't work
I mean it's not working no
um not from our perspective anyway but
we're still there we're not we didn't
abandon it but we're not putting effort
on it we're YouTube shorts yeah we're in
a lot of people in this building working
on that every day yeah you guys crank
those yeah they do they put out a bunch
of them when you think about content for
you are you because you're recording 12
hours a week correct four days a day oh
15 hours okay well not counting
commercial yeah we do three hour talk
radio show every day the entirety of
your kind of content creation and then
the teams take all of that and
disseminate it through all the the
channels
uh
I do a podcast that I just took over
that's color driven on leadership in
small business called entree leadership
took that over in January that and the
Ramsey Show are the only two things I'm
on but Ramsay network has about 10 shows
that are YouTube and or radio and or I
mean we put them on everything but um I
mean the Ken Coleman show is the only
ones on talk radio 75 stations plus
podcast plus YouTube
um deloney John Dr John deloney has a
huge show on uh podcast and YouTube Only
The Rachel Cruz with George Campbell the
smart money happy hours but we saw dust
to every one of those
every one of those can we say soda we're
going to take uh pieces and clips and do
all kinds of things with them instead of
we don't go create uh well I say very
seldom do we go create a YouTube short
of anyone in the building or anything in
the building it is clipped from
something we were already doing so it's
repurposed uh content that was already
developed for something else
you know highly edited yeah I I mean
because I've I've observed what you're
doing and thinking like how can how can
we do even more of that kind of stuff
lots of payroll yeah we're our media is
um all right well uh
this has been phenomenal and uh I'm
honestly just so grateful that uh they
they had me and my team out here
um to uh this is considered Ramsay
Studios is that what this would do yeah
um and uh just also so grateful for that
one tiny tidbit that wow I'm honored I
had a tiny bit to do with all that you
do man you're amazing I'm proud of you
well done
means a lot I appreciate it well thanks
so much for having coming on the game
thank you brother hopefully the
something in the future absolutely you
can count on it